heute ist ein großer tag leute heute
geht's los ein highlight dieser welt
geländer also heute sehr erster band und
was macht man am ersten advent habe ich
natürlich dass seine tage mein gott
[Musik]
so was haben wir denn in diesem dicken
sack fragst du dich selber was ist in
deinem decken sagt so sagt morgen zum
tag gemacht ja ein ganz neue position im
glauben zu gesehen wurden
meine augen erkennen alles ab wie willst
du heute früh haben heute viel vor wir
müssen ein kaufen bevor der
weihnachtsbaum kommt dankeschön plan für
heute also wir geben jetzt einkaufen
weil wir morgen etwas kriegt geiles
vorhaben ankommt untertan waren dem
tannenbaum geschmückt als sehr gut das
wird glaube ich eine schöne aktion
alle konnten
lexmark timo was 150 150 kannte timo es
ist unsere mittel könnten
wir waren beim markt wir waren beim
markt gibt
ich wollte meine schuhe ausziehen
also ich kenne schon verraten was man
morgen machen morgen haben und ich uns
was ganz ganz tolles besonderes
ausgedacht und zwar werden wir in koch
battle machen jetzt schon gesagt und wie
fühlt sich das als solches schon gesagt
hätte wir machen wollen
dafür waren wir heute beim markt und im
supermarkt und darauf bin ich richtig
gespannt und noch mehr kartoffeln
verdoppelt habe ich gekauft ohne
knoblauch wieder tipps und so von timo
spareribs stand das ist ungefähr so der
einkauf und jetzt sitze ich eigentlich
und warte darauf dass meint angeliefert
wird unser tag aber wir haben auch
tannenbäume auf markt gesehen und im
supermarkt ich wusste gar nicht dass
überall tannenbäume so krass verkauft
werden da wo ich herkomme da ist man
quasi zu so einem tannenbaum verkauf
hingegangen eine sache testen wir bevor
sie an bord kommt doch ich bin so
gespannt ich weiß gar nicht die große
tannenbaum sein wird ich weiß gar nicht
wie die dinge zu anliefern
ja das war auch richtig sagen wie ich
umgestellt
nachts offen qlogic dorfclub über
tannenbäume und dann habe ich den davis
stellen wo der tik tok mensch das gesagt
hat tik tok ist marketingmäßig wir waren
schon in so vielen restaurants war wie
sie tickt abgesehen haben wir waren
glaube ich ein tannenbaum geholt weil
ich ihn auf tik tok gesehen habe die
macht von titel ich habe im hagel ich
habe so ein haarföhn geholt
doch wir haben diese fuß maske geholt
wegen tick tack tick tock ist das neue
tram da lässt man sich inspirieren so
ich habe mir gefüllte weinblätter geholt
ich liebe gefüllte weinblätter und er
die probe jetzt leute gefüllte
weinblätter sind richtig android gab es
auch in sesam ringfinger
das war eigentlich irgendwas aber alle
teams die sie da verkaufen sind
kuhmilch oder mit frischkäse und das ist
nicht so gut für mich mal einkaufen die
verrate ich noch nicht was ich kochen
werde timos gericht kennen die auch noch
nicht beendet wann sollte zu abends
kochen und nicht mittags du es mit dass
timo koch das mittagessen nicht auf das
abendessen beim morgen nikolaus ist
wollen wir halt sehr weihnachtlich essen
ich hoffe natürlich ist lecker ich werde
keine entweder nicht in die sich wieder
der letzte penner hier aber leute für
wochen haben richter
jetzt gar nichts mehr bis dieser damit
gibt es für die gäste in frage die
kamera fing für die mir das gut gelesen
infinitum und skyline in den kommentaren
sondern haben sagen ob es gut dass gut
dürfen ich hab mir das geholfen
ja aber ich wollte nur sagen ich baue an
den kommentaren weil du kommentare man
liest wie weiß ich war jetzt einfach
dass dieser weihnachtsbaum kommt dann
zeige ich euch den weihnachtsbaum
beziehungsweise filme wie der
weihnachtsbaum ankommt
[Gelächter]
so
[Musik]
auf dem kleinen tisch dann nähe wo ja
vielleicht schon eher was sind das für
mich ist finde ich zu hoch glaube cloud
zu hoch ausgemacht ist so dass er ihn
jetzt auch macht und dann machst du
musst ein paar geschenke darunter ist es
so dass du sie ja so wenn sie extra ein
podest gestellt wenn man sieht halt
macht mir nicht so cool natürlich offen
besser aus als wenn er einmal so wir
machen einfach mal auf ja ich kann ja in
der zeit schon mal etwas über diesen
krieg erzählen
den habe ich nämlich bei wundert wie
geholt sponsort keine kooperation kein
kontakt zu den aber ich habe gesehen wo
gesagt wurde dass man glaube ich
sechzehn plastikbäume braucht um einen
echten baum im co2 auszugleichen ehe
nicht 16 plastikbäume 16 jahre muss ein
plastikbaum benutzen und dann hat der
mann im tik tok gesagt 'das wunder tree
eine gute alternative ist weil dieser
tannenbaum und letztes jahr hatte ich
auch schon bei dass dieses problem aber
die li tannenbaum der steht ihr bei uns
und nachdem er hier seine arbeit
erledigt hat mit dem der mitgenommen
abgeholt und in den wald für immer
ausgesetzt oder verliert aber auch viele
nadeln
mein garten verschönert
das finde ich auch voll da ist also ich
glaube wir ein bisschen auf den boden
stellen
ich hätte gern gehabt der
natürlicherweise so groß ist aber jetzt
schon der war so teuer und der andere
war ausverkauft die größere variante war
es also hier ist also 140 sind jetzt
einfach runter dass wir einfach mal
sehen wie der bodenlosen die schrägen
der steht wir müssen irgendwie
stabilisieren indem ende der einbauen
aus dem weihnachtsbaumständer wir haben
die wurzel daran da wird doch dann
wieder
wir lassen ihnen jetzt erstmal aushängen
ich meine es besonders die die wir heute
auf dem markt gesehen haben waren um
einiges schöner bin auch ehrlich ich
mache ihnen ehrliche review das ist halt
eher so ein dicker klopft aber ich habe
auch keine top figur also ich habe
gerade die instructions gelesen die man
für dieses wunder trier haben bekommt 48
stunden hängt er sich aus das dekorieren
mit heute ein bisschen schwierig
um seine natürliche form zwar polen man
kann ihn ja schon figurieren hier 100
riemer keine wärme halten sie deswegen
von einer fußball leitungen entfernt wir
haben fußbodenheizung
ja ja das ist doch süß aus und er
brauchte ford ein glas wasser so dass
ich jetzt nämlich sehr hässlich aus dann
steht da nicht auf der fußbodenheizung
und hat aber auch noch einen gewissen
charme also leute obwohl ich im
verrückten berlin wohne was super groß
ist und sehr anonym ist mein dhl boote
doch der alte mensch hat getan was
gebracht
zara home eingekauft ich bin ehrlich ich
habe es bei so ender gesehen und dachte
mir ach ja es gibt noch zara home 99
jetzt gekostet und das muss noch
gewaschen werden
aber ich will trotzdem sehen wie es
aussieht und ich habe hier haben hier
viel ihn diese unterm baum gestellt
hatte ist jetzt alle okay das war's dann
während der baum sich abhängt werde ich
weiter so hinnehmen
die neuen dunkle farben
[Musik]
so ich muss leider zugeben ich bin total
von diesem scheinbar nachzahlen ich weiß
auch nicht warum aber irgendwie macht
das total bock einfach stimmt diese
fehde auszumalen und sich nicht über ein
bild gedanken zu machen wenn dafür muss
man kein talent haben aber irgendwie ist
es voll entspannt einfach mal talentlos
ist zu machen
okay leute und ja was ich euch gesetzt
noch nicht verraten habe weil es mir
schon leid getan hat wir haben wir haben
gleich zehn gemacht aber wir haben nicht
gefällt wir uns einfach mal ausprobiert
und getan und zwar haben wir bei den
ferien gemacht eine fuhr so wurde ganz
gut und die anderen bis hin zu um
gebacken aber die sind sehr lecker
[Musik]
ja du musst keine tragen
das war nur optional baustelle bei dir
mal ausruhen so verstört dass das ist
klar
[Musik]
weiter sagt verlassen was machst du da
schon wieder vorbei
[Musik]
sieht schön aus aber
obwohl es so schön aber du wirst du doch
auch diese litern super dass die stadt
freue mich stört einfach dass ich das
nicht gemacht aber man kennt das
[Musik]
ok wieder auch im staat stand wieder
passiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
voll zu tun
ich habe mich gerade noch so halten
[Musik]
er hat charakter
acht jahre wieder wenn ich muss wieder
aller drückeberger also leider drücken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist jetzt so es ist mir egal es tut
mir leid aber das bleibt so die aufgabe
bei der duh folge gangs mitmachen
wir haben jetzt noch so papier steht
dann werde jetzt auspacken oder nicht
wir haben massiv messe papiersterne
verschafft euch an leute guckt sich
reinzuhängen zuerst mein erster beitrag
wunderschön barak nummer zwei musste
auch die sachen präsentieren
nee das habe ich seit jahren schon sagen
meine erste besondere ja schon da hat er
sogar ein bisschen ski ist der person
new york tätig an wie echtes essen
[Musik]
die waren so teuer ich glaube an eine
der hat irgendwie 15 euro gekostet
separate nordpols
special gruß an so rein raus dieses ding
und das werde ich jedes jahr wieder ein
dreier ist es auch ein ganz tolles
exemplar das kommt auch jedes jahr
wieder am bau
[Musik]
timo leute nur einseitig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da wären zum 1000
ich will wieder einmal waren erneut
zeigt wie man eine rote matt farbene
kugeln an einen über zehn schädel war
das projekt wir fangen schon ein klar
nach hause ziehen sagt klammer eintragen
und so werde ich glaube
[Musik]
aber nicht ich ne doku zu protokoll
damit die ganz kurz mit der situation
umgehen soll
das war jetzt nicht mehr weiterfahren
text leute ich war's nicht möglich
kaputt gegangen ja hier ist ein bisschen
zu sprung aber sieht immer noch schöner
[Musik]
so unser weihnachtsbaums dekoriert damit
ist unser soll für heute getan aber
jetzt finde jetzt sehr schön geworden
also vielleicht legen wir noch ein oder
andere kugel im laufe des abends dran
aber das ist doch nicht normal gute
nacht leute musik ausgeben
ich habe wieder in weihnachtsstimmung
gekommen ich bin jetzt definitiv ganz
doll in weihnachtsstimmung
hallo vanessa hier ich wünsche euch erst
mal einen schönen zweiten advent und
schön nikolaustag und falls sie es nicht
wissen auch mir hat heute geburtstag
also könnt ihr auch naomi alles gute
wünschen
ich höre erst mal mit flockes auf das
problem daran ist ich bin zu oft zu
angespannt weil sie warum es dieses jahr
mir noch irgendwie schwerer fällt
vielleicht durch die ganze krone
situation ich meine wir sind doch alle
irgendwo gerade nicht unsere beste
version deswegen bevor ich irgendwie
weiter mache und es mir später noch
schlechter geht
berechtigt das lieber jetzt hier ab ich
meine wir hatten wunderschöne sieben
tage es hat ja auch spaß gemacht
das problem ist einfach nur das täglich
hochladen beziehungsweise sich immer was
aus seinem alltag ziehen ist ja es ist
schwer wenn man sich auch nicht so gut
fühlen und ich hoffe ihr euch jetzt spaß
gemacht ich meine der tannenbaum sieht
wirklich fantastisch aus ich liebe ihn
absolut er bringt wie so was von der
weihnachtsstimmung
aber so ist das nun mal manchmal
funktioniert es nicht und ich meine
welches jahr habe ich schon mal blog
muss es durchziehen können mir fällt
gerade auf jeden fall schon steine vom
herzen
ich hatte eigentlich nach kooperationen
die ich für block mit eingeplant hatte
das hat mich ein bisschen saft davon
abgehalten das frühzeitig zu beenden
weil ich natürlich diese kooperation
auch einhalten wollte es sind noch keine
verträge unterschrieben deswegen
gebrechliche gerade keine verträge oder
so aber ich fand's halt auch schaden
weil das man auch kooperationen die ich
super gerne machen wollte und natürlich
auch geld verdienen dabei aber das ist
es einfach nicht wert ist was ich aus
dem letzten jahr auf jeden fall gelernt
wurde aus dem jahr noch davor
gesundheits ist mit keinem geld der welt
aufzuwiegen
und ich möchte auch ein gutes vorbild
für euch seien und zu einem guten
vorbild gehört entscheidung zu treffen
die hart sind die aber sich für einen
selber richtig anfühlen und man muss
auch sein herz hören und das tue ich
hiermit und ich wünsche euch noch eine
ganz fantastische weihnachtszeit
wirklich lasst es euch gut gehen
versucht diese zeit zu nutzen um für
euch selber auch dazu seine für eure
familie da zu sein um neue hobbys wie
ausmalen zu finden
vielleicht steckt ein gamer unter euch
und du willst es doch nichts ist auch
ganz gut zum spielen und ansonsten ja
wünsche ich euch ganz viel ganz viel
glück und gesundheit und wir sehen uns
dann in den nächsten tagen vielleicht
mal wieder nicht mal was also dass der
monat ist noch lang wir haben heute
nikolaus der sechste also der monat ist
noch lang da kann man viel kommen aber
ich bin ich brauche eine pause
ich freue mich gerade so wie im winter
das hatte ich hatte heute auch schon
angefangen zu filmen also dass die
entscheidung ist jetzt gerade als
gefallen
warum ihre grenzen kommen gleich vorbei
und wir machen ein schönes abendessen
bei einem geburtstag hat und ich freue
mich darauf das jetzt einfach genießen
zu können wir keine sorgen mehr machen
zu müssen um irgendeinen inhalt
irgendwas festzunehmen